it's about time we just ban everything
we don't like whether it's writing
whether it's videos whether it's spoken
opinions that's the only way you can
truly be free talking about fair use on
YouTube here we can
but that was fast they were really on
top of that line quick so this is a
pretty laid-back people have been asking
us where the why democratic socialism
doesn't work video is gone and usually
we don't really get into internal drama
on social media but we logged in after
our most recent podcast to find this yes
a takedown notice Mashable took down the
why democratic socialism video doesn't
work
Mashable claims that we violated
copyright by using clips in their video
supporting making an argument in support
of socialism which we used to
specifically rebut their arguments on
socialism the clips were taken from this
video you're not gonna you're not gonna
show it I can't know just can we show a
screen I could show you this yeah I
think it was short enough I think it's
still fair use but it's entirely
inappropriate unprofessional brought a
smile to my face now if you've been
following the channel we get slept with
copyright claims all the time Viacom
recently with the Amy Schumer deal but
those are automatic Content ID matches
and they don't count as hard knocks
against our account basically Viacom
these big corporations they
automatically detect if any of their
clips have been used and they either
remove the content or they take your
revenue on YouTube this is an actual
takedown notice which as far as I
understand means that someone at
Mashable manually file the request that
the video be taken down now does this
necessarily mean it's political in
nature not exactly you've seen this from
nostalgia critic a lot of film reviewers
have been hit with these it's a constant
problem for them when dealing with
political speech however you know
contrasted with films they don't want
bad reviews out what does that say here
Mashable doesn't want voices of dissent
they don't want their views looking bad
now if I had to wager with a manual
takedown notice because we are going to
fight this and hopefully it doesn't need
to escalate hopefully Mashable does the
right thing we did not use their entire
video we did not profit from their video
we were simply using it because their
arguments were bad fabric
want a hunch I think it may have
something to do with the fact that
Mashable is a giant tech website company
in our video actually had like 65 times
the play that theirs did that is a
bummer for them yeah it is and it is
ironic that Mashable that has been seen
as this big tech company in a social
media sort of centric platform is using
exactly what you'd hope they'd fight
against you know big corporations trying
to stifle the little guy simply because
they don't like what they have to say so
what exactly does this mean well YouTube
effectively has a guilty until proven
innocent policy to be fair YouTube has
been much more fair than most social
media they've often given us a recourse
available to correct these problems and
in the past they pretty much always have
save for maybe once or twice but this is
a little more serious because if you get
three strikes like this on your account
your channel goes away forever and the
big boys the Mashable's of Viacom they
abuse that system because you can only
fight off so many strikes at a time and
they just try to bury your account with
strikes and hopes that your channel goes
away and they get to maintain their
monopoly or or their control on the
exchange of information I understand for
use we've had people take our videos and
just rip them in their entirety right
the full video and just upload it to
make some money and that's a problem
obviously but if you look at our video
oh damn it you can't I forgot you'll see
that it's it's it falls squarely under
fair use unless you have a judge who
doesn't like to hear people criticize
other opinions or open free speech so
the main thing we're going to try and
work with YouTube here as we fight this
because it's it's wrong and Mashable
knows that it's wrong um we have certain
privileges that we've lost with our
account the most important of which is
the live-streaming
we can't livestream the show on YouTube
right now right it has a huge one yep
they've gone now we can apparently maybe
we can work something out there if not
bookmark latte with crater comm because
we haven't figured out what we'll be
doing for this week or the next week but
we will for sure be live-streaming
whether it's Facebook whether it's
periscope we don't know yet we'll find a
way if we don't remedy it on youtube so
bookmark the website laterthe crater
comm it's free we'd also do articles
there there know a lot of you don't
necessarily read on the YouTube channel
and we're an iTunes SoundCloud mailing
list
it is free we're still going to keep
doing our things but unfortunately if
YouTube is going to acquiesce to these
big boys and then in the realm of
politics if leftists are going to
continue abusing the system to silence
all voices of dissent that they don't
like we have to put some contingency
plans in place we'll get as much as we
can on YouTube we'll fight it as much as
we can but just in case we can't just
just hit two more clicks to bookmark our
website and and check back in
damnit they are on top of they are quick
usually it's a subscribe by clicking my
face so you can subscribe on YouTube but
we're actually at the point where we
want to take you off site so click my
face and you'll go to ladder with credit
comm or you can bookmark it for free and
stay in touch in case you don't see us
here anymore otherwise you can watch one
of these other videos there I assume
they're still up but nobody knows